what makes a terrible pitch oh
probably not enough preparation
not knowing your character or your world
um you know there are Staples to every
pitch everybody needs to know
why why you're the one to write the
pitch the the show
you know
um
you need to know your character really
well you need to know what how they
operate within the world what the
conflict is what are this what's the
Ensemble around them
and if you can't articulate that
it can be
a mess
but I don't think anybody ever walks
into a pitch thinking it's going to be a
terrible pitch they don't want to make a
terrible pitch that's that happens by
accident
but when you know a show and you're
passionate about a show showing that
passion
goes a long way that can really remedy a
lot of ills even if you aren't great at
articulating them in the way that you
think is the smoothest way to do it
I think sometimes just your enthusiasm
for the material and knowing that
material and knowing what you want to
say
can be you know make all the difference
I know it's a it's it terrifies people
it's a terrifying thing to go in there
and
want to tell a story really well and not
wanting to screw up and because you
don't want to screw up you end up
screwing up
but
you have to remember that people have
heard a lot of these things they've
heard a thousand of these pitches and
you're not bringing anything new
it's very rare that you're bringing in
something that's so wholly different
but what you are bringing is yourself
and that coupled with the idea is why
people want you to write it
and remember they're not they're not
creating a show for you to sit and tell
the story on television right that's not
the you pitching is not the show
um the show is what how you're going to
execute it on the page so I think if you
can release some of that anxiety
and just go in and tell us and talk
about why you love something and why you
think it's a great idea
then the details don't matter you know
especially if you if you if you're the
person who comes in with a note card or
you come in with your your page and your
page is shaking acknowledge it and just
go I'm awful at this there are plenty of
people who are terrible pitchers who end
up selling things
so if you could just hang a lantern on
it and just go look I'm gonna botch this
terribly but guess what I love this so
much
and I think you should love it so much
then you know
I think you could I could think you
could sweep by
it sounds like then terrible pitch isn't
uh nervousness it's lack of enthusiasm
well you could be nervous but again
if you're nervous there are so many
other ways to mitigate that so bring a
partner or bring your agent or bring
somebody who's gonna fill in the blanks
think who's gonna you know be your
wingman so there are ways to do that
again you can write it down you can you
can have them you can send them the deck
in advance these days it's it's all on
a zoom zoom has been the best thing in
the world for people who are terrible
pitchers because you can read your
document no one's going to know
so there are ways that you can
get around it
I think you know barring a flop sweat I
think I think anybody can
can muscle through and again it's what
you are on the page so if you they love
you on the page and they've already said
that they've loved you because you're in
that room
whether it's a zoom room where it's in
person so you've already got over the
hurdle the biggest hurdle
and then you just have to convince them
that you have enough
insight into the character and you know
the world really well and there's
something to say
that there's a relevancy to what you're
saying
then you've got a lot of the big pieces
but when someone lacks enthusiasm then
it doesn't matter if they're smooth as
is butter with their delivery but it's
there's just something it's not
convincing well here's the thing who
would want to work with somebody who's
not enthusiastic about a job
because you are then spending
as we said 12 hours a day on set
for 22 Episodes or eight episodes or
however many it's a lot of time
it's
the bulk of your year right you're CR
coming up with a pitch and then getting
in the room to pitch takes a long time
to do it so if you're not interested in
it why do it what's the point
so you have to be enthusiastic otherwise
do something else
if a pitch or screenplay is rejected how
does that writer build a relationship
with the executives
oh
okay when you say rejected though what
are you talking about are you talking
about somebody that
has already sold something and is
rejected or before you even get to the
place where you're meeting for General
you know you're having a general and
it's sorry to pass
okay but if it's again if you're sitting
in the room with an executive you've
already won they are already on your on
on your team right so it's up to you to
then give them something that they
that they will like or maybe it's just
not for them and maybe it's just the
wrong timing so there are there have
always been times when we're looking for
a and you're bringing us B so we really
need a family comedy for this slot but
you're bringing us an action comedy and
we don't have space for it nor can we
afford it whatever it is it might not be
the right time so your past might have
nothing to do with you as a human being
or your writing your skill or your or
you know whether I like you it might be
a factor of many other things that you
have no idea the problem is is that we
always take it personally we think it's
us
you've said no and I take it personally
right
so
you have to get past that because again
as we said before executives are running
a mile a minute
they are
managing a lot of things there's a lot
of balls in the air
and that one thing might not be right so
keep moving let's keep moving
because I've already invited you into my
space I've already said I like your
writing you you now it's on you to say
okay that didn't work let me here's what
I would do if I was in that position
you've just passed to me you go I'm
sorry it's not working I go you know
what
what are you looking for
now there's a whole new conversation or
oh yeah yeah I totally understand that
thank you so much for reading it that's
so great
um
let me float another thing by you
something I'm working on
what do you think about this and then
you've hooked somebody with another I
you don't even have to have the idea you
could say you know what I'm thinking
about doing something about
mother-daughter relationships or
something about you know dystopian
worlds and you know how somebody
navigates that then again you've then
opened up another line of conversation
where then that executive can say
oh and you get something more come back
and Pitch it to me that's a conversation
now how do you land the plane in that
meeting the end of the meeting hopefully
you say you know what my agent put us in
touch I would really love to have a
direct line to you is that okay can I
can I share my card with you or can I
give my information directly to your
assistant or can I have your number or
is it okay if I reach out in a couple
weeks you know there are ways to have a
conversation and particularly if you've
connected over something so let's just
say
you guys both have kids who are in AYSO
hey you know what I wonder are you going
to be at the turkey tournament I would
love to see you let's grab coffee there
whatever it is there are threads
everywhere that you can pull that's why
being in a room a real room with
somebody gives you all of the
other information about that person what
are the posters they have on the wall
what shows did they do what's the coffee
table book that they have everybody's
got a coffee day book
um what's the pictures that are on there
on their desk there's something that you
can then key into and ask that person
about themselves in that way and then
connect it back so that you start a
relationship just as though you would do
with anybody
so there's there are ways to continue
the conversation then too and even if
you don't hear back from them it doesn't
mean that they haven't received the
information there's many times that I
would get an email and I was running so
fast that I didn't think to respond but
I still saw the email I still saw that
person's name
that person still was on my mind
so don't think that a no answer is no
answer
so that's the error is thinking that
it's rejection when really they've
invited you there they've given you
whatever amount of time so that's
actually not a rejection yeah and then
you're it's sort of the door is slightly
open and then it's up to you to make the
next move and to show that you've made
some progress so for and you and we're
we're so good as human beings of filling
in the blanks we're like ah they hated
me and then you go through down a rabbit
hole where you just you just wonder all
the things that you did wrong and I must
have crossed my legs in the wrong place
and I know when I took the Sip I choked
on my water and oh they just hate me and
you go down this place that has
absolutely no bearing on reality
because again they are the star of their
own movie and they're thinking about
something else
they just said oh my God I had a really
great meeting
and I wonder what I'm gonna get back you
know and then it's up to you you have to
deliver
and remember too again we are the a town
of show me something like show me you're
moving forward if you're sitting in
stasis if you're locked in a block of
ice and you are not moving forward I
don't really have time for you I want
the person who's actually out there
doing something
so as soon as we show a little as a as a
writer as soon as you show a little
momentum on your own we will then
re-engage
so you get into a program oh I'm
re-engaging with you or you know you I
don't know
are you with a competition or someone
else has brought your name up and then
I'm re-engaging
so
and you don't know what's happening
under the surface so there's a whole
network of things that happen constantly
that
we are never privy to because no one's
saying I did this for you but there are
also many times where someone would come
in to me meet with me and have a great
meeting I didn't have anything for them
at the time but it didn't mean that I
didn't push that material to the current
department or push that material to a
friend of mine at a different network or
mention that name somewhere or give a
recommendation to that for that writer
to a program so there's a whole other
network of things that are churning
below the service surf surface that are
happening that are really working in
your favor
and eventually all those things are
going to line up somewhere eventually
there's going to be a critical mass and
those people are going to hear your name
a couple of times they're going to go oh
my god I've heard that person's so great
and then so when you your little bubble
Pops to the top that's when your little
Horton Hears a Who Yap comes out right
and all of a sudden we are here we're
here we're here